foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and
House of the dragon video in this video
I want to discuss an incredibly sad and
disturbing scene that may or may not
happen in House of the Dragon season 1
finale on this Sunday this is a scene
that we might see shortly after Rainier
finds out her father viserys has died
the reveal of aceres's death will send a
Shockwave throughout Dragonstone that
will have a shocking effect on rhaenyra
as you all know after rhaenyra and Damon
got married they also had Sons named
aegon in visaris who we've already met
in episode 8 of House of the Dragon in
that same episode where we met renera
and Damon's Sons everyone should have
noticed she had another one on the way
throughout most of that episode renera
had been holding her belly well if also
the dragon will be following George R
Martin's novel Fire and Blood then we
should see renera go into labor in this
final episode of the season and let me
just say viewer discretion should be
advised before this scene is aired now
let me read what George R Martin has
written in Fire and Blood this is how
how everything unfolds immediately after
aegon's Coronation and King's Landing
now after the coronation the remaining
kingsguard escorted aegon to his mount a
splendid dragon with gleaming golden
scales
Sunfire was the name given this Dragon
of the Golden Dawn Grand maester Monken
says how the king aegon flew Thrice
around the city before landing inside
the walls of the red key Sir Eric
Cargill LED his grace into the throne
room where aegon the second of his name
mounted the steps of the Iron Throne
before a thousand Lords and knights
that's when shouts rang through the
Halls now on Dragonstone no cheers were
heard instead there were screams echoing
through the halls and stairwells of the
Sea Dragon Tower down from the
apartments where rhaenyra Targaryen
strained and shuttered in her third day
of Labor her baby had not been due for
another turn of the moon but the news of
her father's death from King's Landing
had driven rhaenyra into a black Fury
and her anger seemed to bring on the
birth as if the Babe inside of her were
angry as well and fighting to get out
rhaenyra's shriek curses all through her
labor calling down the Wrath of the Gods
upon her half-brothers and their mother
Alison Hightower and detailing the
torments she would afflict on them
before she would let them die she cursed
a baby inside of her too mushroom says
while clawing at her swollen belly as
maester gerardis and her Midwife tried
to restrain her and shouting monster
monster get out get out get out when the
babe at last came forth she was indeed a
monster a stillborn girl malformed with
a hole in her chest where her heart
should have been Anna stubby scaled tail
or so mushroom describes her the dwarf
says that it was he who carried the
little thing to the yard for burning the
dead girl had been named vicenia renera
announced the next day when the milk of
the poppy had blunted the edge of her
suffering rhaenyra said she was my only
daughter and they killed her they stole
my crown and murdered my daughter and
they shall answer for it and so the
dance of the Dragons began as rhaenyra
called a council of her own known as the
black Council setting it against the
Green Council of King's Landing renera
herself was there seated in the middle
of her husband Damon Targaryen and her
trusted counselor maester gerardis her
three sons were there with them though
none had reached the age of manhood Jace
was 14 Luke 13 and Joffrey only but 11.
a few members of the kingsguard stood
with them Sir Eric Cargill and the
Westerman saw Laurent Mar brand 30
nights a hundred crossbow men and 300
men at Arms made up the rest of
dragonstone's Garrison this Army leaves
something to be desired Damon observed
sourly a dozen lesser Lords Bannerman
and vessels to Dragonstone set at the
black Council as well but the greatest
Lord to swear fealty to rhaenyra was
Corliss valerion of drift Mark although
the sea snake had grown old he liked to
say that he was barely holding on to
life like a sailor holding onto the
wreckage of a sunken ship however he
also said mayhaps the seven have saved
me for this one last fight and with Lord
Corliss valerion came his wife rainy
Targaryen who was 5 and 50. her face
laying in and lined yet she was fierce
and fearless as she had been when she
was much younger those who sat at the
black Council counted themselves loyal
but knew full well that king aegon would
name them as traitors each of them had
already received a summons from King's
Landing demanding they show themselves
that the red keep to swear an oath of
loyalty to the new king all their forces
combined could not match the power the
hightowers could alone field aegon's
greens enjoyed other advantages as well
Old Town King's Landing and lanasport
were the largest and richest cities in
the realm all three were held by the
greens every visible symbol of
legitimacy belonged to aegon he set on
the Iron Throne he lived in the red keep
he wore the conqueror's crown and
wielded The conqueror's Sword and had
been anointed by acceptance of the faith
before the eyes of thousands Grand
maester Orwell said in his councils and
the Lord commander of the kingsguard had
set the crown on his head and he was a
male which in the eye eyes of many made
him the rightful King his half-sister
raniera the usurper now against all that
rhaenyra's advantages were few some
older Lords might yet recall the oath
they had sworn when she was made her
father's Heir there had been a time when
she had been well loved by Highborn and
Commons alike when they cheered her as
the realm's Delight many a young Lord
and Noble Knight had sought her favor
then though how many would still fight
for her now that she was a woman wed her
body aged and thickened by six
childbirths was a question none could
answer though her half-brother had
looted their father's treasury renera
had at her disposal the wealth of house
valerion and the Sea snake's Fleet gave
her superiority at Sea in her consort
Damon Targaryen was Battle tested in the
stepstones had more experience of
warfare than all of her foes combined
and last but far from least rhaenera
Targaryen had her dragons
when Ravens carried the news of aegon's
Coronation to Dragonstone princess
rhaenyra summoned her own black Council
with her was her uncle and husband Damon
Targaryen considered by many to be the
most dangerous man in Westeros
few Lords supported her but the greatest
of these was Corliss Valerian who
controlled the largest Fleet in the
realm and his Targaryen wife rhaenys the
old King's sister
then there were her five Sons although
none grown to manhood the pitiful
assembly really combined they couldn't
match the power of house Hightower alone
but rhaenyra had dragons
she Damon and rhaenys rode huge and
formidable beasts and three of her five
Sons were Riders as well
Dragonstone also housed six more Dragons
without Riders
[Music]
[Music]
foreign